[Musik]
hallo zusammen
was ist denn hier
hallo ihr Lieben heute machen wir einen
weiteren basic Kuchen den man eigentlich
immer mag den alle lieben es wird ein
super saftiger Zitronen Rührkuchen und
dafür lege ich jetzt direkt los denn ihr
wisst ich mag es nicht lange um den
heißen Brei zu quatschen und möchte euch
direkt das Rezept abliefern ich habe
hier meine Zimmer warme Butter bzw heute
ist es Margarine weil ich das von einem
Rezept für eine vegane Torte einfach
noch da hatte also könnt ihr in diesem
Rezept Butter oder Margarine verwenden
und dazu gebe ich jetzt noch Zucker eine
Prise Salz die hebt den süßen Geschmack
bzw unterstreicht einfach den süßen
Geschmack und Vanilleextrakt denn zu
einem Zitronenkuchen gehört auf jeden
Fall auch noch Vanille ich finde das
sind zwei Aromen zwei Zutaten die
einfach perfekt miteinander harmonieren
da gibt es einfach mein Vanilleextrakt
dazu da braucht ihr auch nicht viel weil
das ist schon sehr es schmeckt schon
sehr intensiv also nicht zu viel
vanillekuchen werden sondern ein
Zitronenkuchen und jetzt werde ich das
ganze ca 3 Minuten lang mit meiner
Küchenmaschine verrühren ich habe jetzt
hier den Haken mit der Gummilippe dran
und werde dann gleich auswechseln aber
hier ist das eigentlich ganz gut damit
er auch die Butter schön am Schüsselrand
noch mal mitnimmt also drei Minuten
mixen und dann geht's weiter
[Musik]
so die Butter ist jetzt richtig schön
weich und auch ein bisschen heller
geworden die Konsistenz ist perfekt und
weiter geht's mit den Eiern die haben
jetzt bei mir Zimmertemperatur dann
verbindet sich das einfach besser wenn
Sie jetzt kalt aus dem Kühlschrank
kommen ist es jetzt auch nicht ganz so
dramatisch aber es ist halt schöner weil
sich das ganze einfach besser verbindet
und ich schlage das jetzt erst hier rein
und dann dort rein in einem Video hat
jemand von euch geschrieben ähm ja aber
da können auch Eierschalen mit
reinkommen ja das stimmt aber ich habe
da immer so Selbstvertrauen und schlag
das Ei direkt da rein aber hier so als
Tipp wenn ihr euch unsicher seid das
Eierschale in den Teig kommt einfach
separat hier aufschlagen und dann in den
Teig geben und ich rühre das jetzt immer
nach und nach unten und dann lass das
dann einmal kurz mit dem Teig verbinden
so jetzt habe ich mich vertan wollte ich
nämlich den Schneebesen aufsetzen lieber
dran machen also der geht auch das ist
auch kein Problem wenn den Handrührer
habt dann könnt ihr ja auch nicht so
switchen ähm das funktioniert auch alles
aber besser funktioniert das einfach
wenn man jetzt den Schneebesen Aufsatz
verwendet weil sich das einfach viel
besser miteinander verbindet gleich auch
die trockenen Zutaten daher Switche ich
den auch sonst jetzt einmal kurz
[Musik]
ist euch übrigens aufgefallen dass ich
mir extra was gelbes angezogen habe nur
für diese zitronentorte ich hatte sogar
was anderes an ich hatte sogar was
anderes an mich extra umgezogen weil ich
dachte so zur Feier des Tages was
verbindet ihr eigentlich mit einem
Zitronenkuchen weil ich habe so eine
ganz bestimmte so so ein ganz bestimmte
Erinnerung einfach wo wir Kinder waren
meine Schwester und ich angefangen haben
einfach ein Zitronenkuchen zu backen das
ging voll daneben aber am Ende war es
halt irgendwie lecker aber der hat
extrem nach Backpulver geschmeckt
irgendwas haben wir damals falsch
gemacht ach warum schneide ich die
Zitrone durch ich bin mir doch erstmal
die Schale Krallen ihr braucht übrigens
unbedingt hat jetzt muss ich mal ganz
kurz suchen ihr braucht übrigens
unbedingt Bio Zitronen die sind nämlich
nicht gespritzt und nur da dürfte die
Schale verzehren daher ist es so wichtig
dass es Bio ist so und da habe ich jetzt
erstmal die Schale rein ich habe jetzt
hier zwei kleine Bio Zitronen aber ich
schreibe euch ja ganz ohne hin unten in
die Infobox dann könnt ihr das ganz
einfach screenshotten nachmachen
einkaufen gehen aber
wenn ihr eine große Zitrone habt dann
braucht ihr nur eine denn ihr müsst euch
vorstellen ich nehme jetzt auch gleich
den Saft von zwei kleinen Zitronen aber
falls ihr einkauft und die bekommen nur
diese Riesen Zitronen dann könnte das
viel zu viel Saft sein und daher immer
darauf achten ob es große oder kleine
sind übrigens ganz wichtig das kann auch
sein dass das der Fehler damals war bei
meiner Schwester mir ja mit Sicherheit
dass ich eher drauf gekommen bin ganz
wichtig ihr dürft niemals unter der
gelben Schale das weiße mit reiben das
das ist so bitter das schmeckt so
komisch dass das einfach nicht mit rein
und da immer ganz vorsichtig immer
gucken dass Sie nicht zu viel reibt und
wirklich nur die gelbe Schale krass ich
komme dahinter 20 Jahre später okay so
alt bin ich noch nicht 15 Jahre später
komme ich dahinter
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt den Saft noch mit dazu
gepresst und ich liebe meine
Zitronenpresse das muss ich einfach mal
erwähnen weil er auch die ganzen Kerne
aufhängen und ich weiß noch wie ich mal
rumgewühlt habe bei meinen Kerner
reingefallen ist und das ist einfach
geil ich verlinke euch gerne in die
Infobox genauso wie alle anderen Dinge
die ich so nutze und das also der Rest
den könnt ihr jetzt in die Spülmaschine
werfen das ist gut fürs Geschirr das
riecht dann noch anschließend gut und
das hat man dann also mehr Verwertung
geht glaube ich gar nicht deswegen
schmeißt das hier direkt mit rein zack
einfach irgendwo verteilen
und dann geht es weiter übrigens habe
ich noch einen Tipp weil wie gesagt bei
Zitronenkuchen denke ich halt immer so
meine Kindheit und damals hatte ich zum
Beispiel so eine schöne feine Reibe noch
nicht und ich hatte nur diese große
Vierkantreibe da könnt ihr dann einfach
wenn ihr die gerade nicht da habt
einfach ein Backpapier auf die wisst ihr
was das zeige ich euch jetzt eben ich
hätte mich gefreut damals so einen Tipp
zu bekommen weil ich war fast
verzweifelt und kam dann irgendwie drauf
und den Trick zeige ich euch jetzt und
dann geht's weiter mit dem Teig so wenn
jetzt die Zitronenschale hier reiben
würde dann bekommt ihr richtig große
Stücke und ihr seid vermutlich auch
unter der gelben Schale also bekommt die
bittere weiße Schale mit dann gibt's ja
noch andere Seiten die sind aber auch
nicht so optimal weil wenn ihr jetzt
anfangen hier bei der feinen Seite die
Zitrone zu reiben dann setzt sich das
richtig fest und ihr müsst euch das
irgendwie wieder rauskratzen daher
einfach ein Backpapier hier drauf geben
so
und dann können wir gerne ein bisschen
fest drücken und dann mit der Zitrone
darauf reiben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so wenn ihr das backt
wenn ihr das Backpapier abnehmen dann
habt ihr hier den die schöne
Zitronenschale und so habe ich das
damals gemacht zack das nicht schön also
ein kleiner Tipp nebenbei falls jetzt
dieses praktische diese ganz praktische
feine Reibe nicht da habt und jetzt
geht's weiter mit dem trockenen Zutaten
[Musik]
so der Zitronensaft ist drin ich habe
jetzt hier mehl Speisestärke und
Backpulver vorab miteinander verrührt
die Speisestärke macht einfach den
Kuchen ein bisschen lockerer solltet
jetzt gerade keine Stärke da haben
einfach die gleiche Menge durch Mehl
ersetzen also 40 Gramm mehr Mehl
verwenden aber ich mag das ganz gerne
mit der Speisestärke so das müsste jetzt
auch nicht sieben das ist hier nicht
notwendig bei dem Teig einfach jetzt
löffelweise mit dazugeben dann einrühren
und immer abwechselnd die Milch mit
dazugeben die Milch habe ich so ein
bisschen erwärmt das heißt die Zimmer
warm und nicht ganz so kalt damit es
besser verrührt ja wenn ihr alles damit
rein gegeben habt dann ist der Teig
fertig
[Musik]
vor der Teig ist jetzt schon ultra
fluffig also der gefällt mir richtig gut
und jetzt kommt der hier in meine eckige
Form und ich brauche jetzt keinen
Backpapier unten drunter geben da ist
die Beschichtung schon perfekt und ich
habe ja auch Butter bzw Margarine im
Teig da Biskuitböden wenn jetzt so viel
gar kein Fett drin ist gebe ich auch
gerne mal so ein bisschen Backpapier und
runter aber hier könnt ihr euch das
einfach sparen so Backofen ist auch
schon vorgeheizt auf 180 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze und dann wird er da einfach
drin da gebacken wir gehen noch mal
schön hoch und wir machen einen
klassischen Puderzucker ich finde das
gehört einfach immer mit dazu
[Musik]
bei mir hat der Zitronenkuchen jetzt 45
Minuten gebraucht macht gern die
Stäbchenprobe um zu schauen ob der
Kuchen komplett gar ist kann sein dass
wenn ihr so eine standardbrotkastenform
habt dass er dann vielleicht fünf
Minuten länger braucht so und jetzt
einmal drüber auf ein schönes
Serviertablett ich habe das jetzt einmal
vollständig abkühlen lassen und jetzt
kommt der einfache Guss ich glaube den
kennt jeder dafür nimmt ihr euch einfach
Puderzucker ein bisschen Zitronensaft
und das war's und dann kommt das einfach
noch mal als Abschluss auf unseren
saftigen Kuchen
[Musik]
also ich glaube man sieht schon dass der
saftig ist
also auf dem Kanal haben wir einen
gemacht in einem Küche das ist aber so
ein Blechkuchen
YouTube und deswegen kommen jetzt gerade
lecker
[Musik]
perfekt geworden
ich könnte das Weg atmen
kann
alles essen
so ungefähr 18 Uhr wir haben eigentlich
nur gefrühstückt heute morgen
ganz ehrlich ich schaue den jetzt weg
unbedingt
nachmachen und schreibt mir jetzt
unbedingt in die Kommentare welches
basic-rezept ihr als sehen möchtet und
dann mache ich das und ich würde sagen
wenn ich dann euren Kommentar auswähle
grüße ich sogar die Person beim nächsten
Video habe ich lange nicht mehr gemacht
ich sitz mal war vor ungefähr 5 Jahren
alles so richtig oldschool heute also
viel Spaß beim Nachbacken und bis zum
nächsten mal auf meinem Kanal tschüss
[Musik]